[Music]
season two is finally here tonight
really I know we left season with a lot
of questions when you got that first
script for season two what did you think
what was your reaction I just utter
disbelief I was blown away I thought
okay well let's see how we ease back
into this how you know but they waste no
time I mean we hit the ground running in
a way that I don't think anybody saw
coming where do we pick up with Dolores
well I think the showrunners have said
we're not picking up sort of exactly
where we left off but we're going to
pick up in the aftermath a bit and we're
gonna see definitely in the first
episode where Dolores is at with herself
her many selves is that challenging as
an actress to go in and how only having
one script at a time it's the hardest
thing I've ever done and I spoke to
Jordan Lisa before season two started to
kind of okay so where's Dolores now is
there anything I can watch over there
any references like with Tony and going
for and who Jonah just goes I don't
think there's ever been a character like
this like great oh cool there's no
pressure it's never been done so it
really was interesting finding where she
is and who she is now and what I love
about the character is that I think
there's endless possibilities she can be
whoever she wants to be so yeah that
Super Bowl spot yeah we can say this
we can burn it to the ground
[Music]
from the ashes building world
[Applause]
[Music]
our world makes this thing that Dolores
is just out to destroy this world right
is that her mission this season you know
I I don't I don't know I I think much
like anything in Westworld it's always
more complicated than you think I think
she definitely wants her freedom and she
wants access to the world that's been
denied to her I don't know if her
endgame is destroying it yet or not I
think that's gonna be something that
we're gonna explore a bit more okay we
have some first look photos out there we
know Dolores is in modern day clothes
yep so she's out in the world right I
know I was like oh wow we're releasing
that okay cool how does Dolores function
in the modern world uh well I think
that's gonna be something that we're
gonna see more of you know and I think
we've established that we you know
there's different timelines there's that
you know I think we're gonna we're going
to I mean I'm trying to like talk about
it without giving anything away I don't
know you know it's it's I don't know if
I could answer that have to wait and see
on them not the way to see yeah and
we've been teased with some other worlds
yeah well we see Dolores in any of these
other worlds sure I mean I don't know I
I don't want to answer that
really I'll take it sure yeah and then I
mean it depends what kind of I mean I
don't know what kind of roads we're
talking about big question Dolores and
Maeve are kind of on separate paths a
little bit well we see them interact
this season well I think it would be a
tragedy if Dolores and may have never
interacted I think that tanning I would
start a riot but I think it will be
probably in ways that people don't
expect okay as usual
yeah with this show yeah yeah they've
very different objectives yes are we
gonna see Dolores and Teddy back
together yes yeah uh I think this season
them it's gonna be the first time that
they're really interacting off script
you know and and finding out what the
relationship is now that there are no
barriers and no narratives and if that
love is real you know or just imagined
and but I think Teddy and Dolores is
connection is runs very very deep and
even though certain things are
programming that doesn't necessarily
mean they're not real you know just
because you program love doesn't mean it
doesn't feel like love so I think it
there's journey this season will be what
are we know that we have access to
ourselves and can our love sustain a war
basically what was your one big question
leftover from season one this may be
slightly self-centered but I just wanted
to know who Dolores was now I wanted to
know who why it was because you just
kind of just got this information that
oh by the way she also has this Jekyll
and Hyde alter ego that lives inside of
her that comes out every now and then
but so what happens if she has access to
all of her selves all at once what does
that mean what does that look like
who is Wyatt that's what I wanted to
know and I definitely found out I was
going to say did you get your answer
there I guess yes I did
Wow it was really intense why it is very
intense but I also thought I was coming
back and playing like somebody with the
soul of a man that why it was this man
and I was gonna have this but then they
reminded me that why it can also be a
girl's name
yes I was wrong oh they throw a
challenge after challenge at you yeah
have you had to sum up season 2 with
just one word what would that word be
chaos okay Oz complete chaos
you
[Music]